>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Larry Appelbaum: Hi.
My name is Larry Appelbaum from the
Music Division here at the Library
of Congress, and I'm pleased to say
joining us is composer, arranger,
band leader, Maria Schneider.
Nice to see you again.
>> Maria Schneider: Good to see you.
>> Larry Appelbaum: Yeah, we
spent some time this morning going
through some treasures in the
collection, jazz and otherwise.
I want to -- I want you to tell
our viewers what made an impression
on you?
What resonated?
What moved you?
>> Maria Schneider:
It's just for me,
I love seeing what a
composer puts to paper,
seeing what their process is,
imagining the thought
going down on the paper.
And, you know, for years,
I was a music copyist,
and I still write in pen and pencil.
And I always enjoyed the -- seeing
maybe even the speed and the --
the confidence which you can see
somebody put down their ideas or --
The Bartok we looked at today where
you could see -- Actually, you know,
he was making his own bar lines
down and the score and everything
and you see he did it from the
hospital, writing concerto for --
>> Larry Appelbaum: Orchestra.
>> Maria Schneider: -- orchestra.
>> Larry Appelbaum: Yeah.
>> Maria Schneider: And
yeah, it was just fun.
And I enjoyed also seeing some
of the letters, because I am one
of those people that's very
interested in the person
and the relationships
and everything that makes
up who they are as a musician.
I never think even in my own music,
I don't think of writing
music as music.
To me, music is a conduit for
life and so knowing and the fact
that you have these archives
and knowing a little bit
about these people's lives
through letters and things
like that just enriches it.
It's --
>> Larry Appelbaum: When's the
last time you wrote a letter?
>> Maria Schneider: An
actual handwritten letter?
I send postcards and letters still.
>> Larry Appelbaum: Oh really?
>> Maria Schneider: Yeah.
>> Larry Appelbaum: Wonderful.
>> Maria Schneider:
I mean, mostly email,
but if there's somebody I really
want to write something too,
I'll still put it in a
postcard or a card, yeah.
>> Larry Appelbaum: Now
you mention the Bartok.
That was a commission.
It was from the mid-1940s --
I think 1943 he finished it.
You -- You've undertaken
a commission
for the library's concert this week.
I want you to tell us a little
bit about that commission.
Have you finished it?
>> Maria Schneider: Yes,
yes, I finished, although --
although, you know,
we're rehearsing.
And for me, Peter Sellars
years ago --
Peter Sellars commissioned me
to write something for my band.
>> Larry Appelbaum: The director.
>> Maria Schneider: Yes.
>> Larry Appelbaum: Yeah.
>> Maria Schneider:
Yeah, the director, yes,
for the Mozart Festival in Vienna.
And I wrote a piece -- Actually,
we're going to close our concert
with called Cerulean Skies.
And when we premiered
it, you know, I was --
You know, it's always a little bit
of a work in progress, so, you know,
I always end up doing editing.
So -- And he said, Maria,
the premiere is never quite,
you know, where it's going to be.
It's the first act and
then you do, and so,
I hope we're going
to be okay, you know?
But it's scary because I did it,
something that's a
little bit unusual.
It has different kinds of
gestures and rhythmic things
that the band is playing that I
am just indicating with my body.
The piece is called Data
Lords, and it's piece that's
about this seduction of all of us
through actually the use of music
and video and all these
things that people --
that corporations like YouTube
and Google use to draw eyeballs
so that they can gather
data and turn it into money.
And these big data companies
I see them that they are now
like data lords and we
are kind of the serfdom.
And it's just taking so much.
It's literally just sucking
the life out of our economy,
our music economy and also
out of I think a certain --
It's the total opposite of what we
did today, that thing of looking
at the real thing, the pencil to the
paper, the thing that the paper made
as opposed to this sort of
plasticized, digitized thing
that just is churned out.
It's like force-feeding, you
know, yourself at the, you know,
the trough or something
like that -- the trough --
You know the fast food --
I mean that's how people
are getting their music.
And so it's this idea that
we're all just giving this away
and this intelligence of this thing
because of all this data is
getting bigger and bigger,
and they know that there
is a point at which
that intelligence will become more
than ours, that it will know more.
We're already at the point where
that data turns into knowledge
about people and disease
or certain things,
and they don't even really
understand what those things are,
but that they can predict
things because of all that data.
So anyway, this is a piece
that has -- It has --
I don't know if you'd call
it some beauty but seduction,
but then it kind of overtakes you.
So there's these gestures
of the band doing
like [makes musical
sound], you know.
So we're still -- we're
still getting that, you know.
It's a little bit of a dance.
So hopefully we'll be well-prepared.
It's a little intimidating
when you say Bartok's concerto
for orchestra was commissioned
by the Library of Congress.
>> Larry Appelbaum:
Well, it's all music.
>> Maria Schneider: Yes.
Well, that it is.
>> Larry Appelbaum: Yes.
So in an era of data lords,
what happens to artists' rights?
>> Maria Schneider: Well, there's
been this kind of wholesale idea fed
to artists which artists had
bought into for decades and decades
that exposure at all
costs; you know,
I don't really care
what the contract says.
I don't really understand it.
I just want to get
my music out there.
And so of course something
like YouTube uses that.
Hey, look at all the
exposure you're going to get.
So, you know -- so we've so
completely overexposed ourselves,
and then they've now
created this culture.
They make it so easy to put things
up -- difficult to take it down --
impossible to take
it down effectively.
Google, you know, you can't keep
up with the BitTorrenting and,
you know, the Torrent
sites and all these things.
And so they purposely don't ask
questions when you upload it.
When you take it down, you get
asked all sorts of questions.
And so what was your question again?
I forgot what was the --
>> Larry Appelbaum: Oh,
about artists' rights --
>> Maria Schneider: Oh
the artists' rights.
>> Larry Appelbaum: -- [inaudible].
>> Maria Schneider: So there's
no -- There are no rights there.
I mean there's no law
holding them accountable
for inducing this infringement.
They monetize it through ads.
It doesn't come to the
musicians, and it's --
There's such an erosion of rights.
I mean most artists that I know now
are telling me that their royalties
and things from their various
sources are about ten percent
of what they were and
it is that bad.
It is really that bad, so, yeah.
>> Larry Appelbaum:
Is it impacting you --
>> Maria Schneider: Absolutely.
>> Larry Appelbaum: -- directly?
>> Maria Schneider:
Well, in different ways.
I notice the impact definitely on
my performance royalties like the --
you know, the -- Because
now what's happening,
it used to be that
music had a value.
Music had a value.
We said it costs this much
to make music, make a record,
we're going to price this
record at such and such.
You know, this is what it costs.
>> Larry Appelbaum: So does
this impact you directly?
>> Maria Schneider: It's
impacted me in a very big way
and it shaped the way
I do things now.
So, one of the things that are
going on is that it used to be
that people set their price,
like this shirt, you know.
What does it cost for the materials?
What does it cost to make it?
The store that buys the shirt
pays that to the manufacturer,
the designer or all those
things and then sells the shirt.
When you buy the shirt,
they aren't --
They're pricing according to what
they have to pay for that shirt.
So now in the music business
with streaming and everything,
what's happening -- and the
government is setting some
of these standards that it just to
me -- It does not make sense at all.
They are paying musicians
for the music.
They're paying for the music.
The creator, the performers,
everything are being paid according
to a percentage of the
net profit of a company,
what they say their
profit is or isn't.
So a company like Spotify is
paying, you know, is saying,
well this is all the money
we have to divvy out,
so you get 0.0007 cents
for a stream.
You know, where -- I
mean that's just insanity
because I know what it
costs to produce a record.
For me to produce one of my
records costs about 200,000 dollars.
You're never going to pay for that
stream and you're never going to pay
through that -- through
any of these things.
So, years ago already
in 2003, you know,
just when the file sharing thing
was starting, before anybody talked
about Crowd Funding, Fan
Funding, it didn't exist.
It was invented by this guy, Brian
Camelio who started ArtistShare.
And he came to me one day because
he knew I was frustrated already
with the record model, which also
had a very historically has had
very, you know, eschewed ways
of calculating recruitment.
It's always been like that.
It's like a credit card company.
You know, you just, you
can never really get ahead
of that credit card debt, and
that's how they treated, you know,
the price of making a record.
So this guy came to
me and said, what's --
And this is what we discussed
today looking at the archive --
the archive -- Your
archive shows process
and shows the creative process.
So Brian said to me
this day, he said,
I came up with an incredible idea.
He said, what's the one
thing nobody can file share?
I -- I don't know.
Seems they can file share anything.
He said, the creative file process.
He said, I'm going to design a
website where you can say to people,
hey, preorder -- You know,
we can bring in people
on different levels fan funding.
He called it fan funding.
And they turned it -- People called
it crowd funding, but we just sort
of privately we're doing this.
So Brian said, I'll call it Fan
Funding and we will get people
to preorder and we will through
my site, document the process.
Show your creative process video of
how you write putting up sketches,
you know, so that people can
download them and have access
to that, so that the fan feels
like they're getting more
than just getting a record.
They can't get that when they
just file share or something,
and it's developing
this relationship.
On top of it, I am setting my
own price and here's the thing
that gets away from
the data lord thing --
Data lords own all the data.
Nobody else does.
We just give it away for
the convenience and the joy
of gorging ourselves in all this
music that we take in so much
that we don't even
really take it in anymore.
In the case of this, I'm
setting my own price.
I know what it costs and I'm
making the lion's share of gross
without all these -- So I'm --
I've been doing this now
and developing a fan base
and an archive, a massive
archive of interviews and --
I go back and look at me
talking about my creative process
for a commission I did, you know,
through my website years ago,
and I'm like, oh wow, yeah,
I went through that too.
Yeah, that thing I'm talking
about with data lords, oh yeah.
I was really scared for
that premiere too, you know.
So -- And it's even fun for
me to see my own process.
So it's very much -- It's my own
little mini-at home ArtistShare
Library of Congress.
And so that has largely -- For
me, it's largely protected,
and I wish every artist would do
that because this business out there
like the streaming and
everything, they are nothing.
They are absolutely
nothing without the music
if musicians didn't give away
the rights, if they didn't sign
and if they weren't signed
on with these companies
that have now joined the data lords.
So, you know, the biggest record
companies like Universal, Warner --
Universal, Warner, Sony, they
all took equity in Spotify.
But Spotify is not in
the music business.
Spotify is in the data business.
So, they use music as the
carrot to draw the eyeballs,
to gather the data to get
the advertising, you know --
I forget, I have to ask somebody.
There's a statistic of the vast,
vast majority of their employees
are data analytic scientists.
You know, they're not
in the music business.
So, this is, you know -- This is
kind of what we're all up against,
and if musicians said, No.
I'm taking it back, they
would -- they would crumble.
They would crumble.
The only ones maybe that wouldn't
is YouTube that somehow, you know,
the government kind of seems so
far and hopefully they're going
to change the safe harbor provision
of the Digital Millennium
Copyright Act,
maybe that's going to get changed.
And they'll start saying, hey,
if you induce this infringement,
you know, if you're basically like a
drug pusher on the street, you know,
or just one, you know, just put up
one -- one little video, you know --
>> Larry Appelbaum:
First one's free.
>> Maria Schneider:
Yeah, first one's free.
You know and it is kind of that bag,
they have this copyright basics
video that is just like --
It's just -- it's just
-- it's unthinkably bad.
It's ridiculous.
So anyway, we'll see what
happens, but, you know,
no one can count on government.
We -- I have to tell you
one thing that we started.
A group of us in New York started
something called Musicanswers --
Musicanswers.org.
It's grassroots, and our
idea was that we want
to start educating musicians to
these issues, waking them up.
It's like, hey folks.
For a century now, we've all
been sleeping and now, I mean,
the alarm bells were
going off before.
Now it's like out of control.
Time to wake up, know
what's going on.
We could have examples up of
everything that should always be
in a publishing contract,
everything that should never be
everything that should always be
in a record contract, and we --
we're getting all these endorsers,
everybody from all over the music
business, everybody from Carol King
to -- to Herbie Hancock to Steve Ray
to students, so that everybody says,
hey, you know what, we -- What we
do is an -- is an asset, and what --
I -- I have to tell you just a --
tell you a little bit
about the public.
So we had a concert the other
night, and we -- My band --
I mean these players,
they're just so extraordinary.
It's a little, you know --
It's a lifetime of obsession
to become a player
like these guys play.
Every day the investment and
the time, the self-criticism,
the study, the -- It's incredible.
What they represent is unbelievable.
So we did a concert and
the audience loved it --
standing ovation afterwards.
This woman -- We had a
reception, and this woman,
and I think she was
one of the people
that help give money
to the concerts.
So a wonderful woman comes up to
Scott Robinson, and she says --
She said -- she said, do you
know that was just marvelous.
My friends and I sat there and we
had the best time trying to figure
out what all of your
professions were.
And one of the guys was
sitting next to Scott
and he said -- He was
standing there.
He said, he's a mad
scientist, and she said,
I thought you were a scientist,
and Scott was just like, wow.
He said, lady, you
just made my journal.
You know, but this is -- This
idea that people have out there
that music is just something.
It just sort of comes and we
just kind of do it on the side,
and then I -- I guess the rest
of the time we're doing
something else, you know.
I guess people just don't realize
that it requires more dedication
than anything else can, you know.
>> Larry Appelbaum:
And -- and commitment.
>> Maria Schneider:
Commitment and loss.
>> Larry Appelbaum: Think of --
think of all the musicians
I your orchestra,
many of whom have been
with you for 25 years.
>> Maria Schneider: Yeah.
>> Larry Appelbaum: That's
a serious undertaking.
>> Maria Schneider: Yeah.
>> Larry Appelbaum: You invest
time, resources and it's worth it,
because look what comes
out the other end.
>> Maria Schneider: Yeah.
They're an evolution of something
that you could never force
and put -- You know, all this
music has evolved slowly over time,
the sound of the band, that's
kind of what I'm talking too
with premieres and everything --
all these things they have a process
and the longer -- George Wein, I
had dinner him not that long ago,
and he was saying, Maria, he said,
you're one of the few musicians
that sticks together with a group.
And he said nobody does
that anymore, and he said,
that's why it's got that sound
and everybody develops in jazz.
What's so great is when you have
that, then you have that trust.
Everybody knows each other so well.
And what that means is then
you can take more risks,
because when you play, you
can throw something out there
and everybody knows, everybody
has each other's back and knows --
and they know my music so well that
they know kind of the outer limit.
They compress it to see if they
can still create the overall sense
of inevitability, and that's what
I'm always looking for in a piece --
that the whole thing has
a sense of inevitability,
but is filled with surprise
and for all of us, you know,
and the unexpected risk taking.
And that's the benefit
of having musicians.
You work with that bond.
You get that.
>> Larry Appelbaum: It's
intriguing to know the dedication
and commitment of your
musicians to the orchestra.
But there's also a level of
dedication and commitment
on the part of the audience
to investing in your process.
>> Maria Schneider: Yeah.
>> Larry Appelbaum:
And they feel finally
that it's not some
corporate entity who's giving
or selling them a commercial
product.
>> Maria Schneider: Yes.
>> Larry Appelbaum: They actually
feel a part of that process.
>> Maria Schneider: Yeah, yeah, it
-- So when we did our first project,
the first ArtistShare project, it
was my record concert in the garden
which to this day is record that
maybe most kind of hits my heart.
There was some -- there were a
lot of things about that record
that were powerful
switchovers for me.
And then add with the
ArtistShare thing, you know.
And we won a Grammy, and it was
the first Grammy that was won
by somebody only selling
on the internet,
and we didn't even realize it to
say it at the time because it was
so early, we almost didn't even
really know what we had started.
But it was the first
fan-funded Grammy.
I'm absolutely sure of it.
So, you know, that -- that
record after that won a Grammy,
I started getting all these emails
from people saying, you know,
it's crazy, but I feel
really proud of this.
And I know I wasn't
part of the music,
but somehow I felt like I was.
And that is what we wanted is
that everybody they felt like --
And when I made that record even in
the graphics on one of the booklets,
I had the names of all the
high participants mixed
in with the players in the
band, as if to say, we all --
>> Larry Appelbaum: Right.
>> Maria Schneider: We are
all this music together.
We all make this together.
We cannot do this alone.
Yeah, most those people still are
coming back and commissioning works
through the site, and
it's -- it's great.
And as an artist, it
also feels really good
to be supportive that way.
It's like -- It is like the old
patron thing a little bit too.
It's nice.
>> Larry Appelbaum: So if
it's a model that works,
why don't more people join?
>> Maria Schneider: I think for
a lot of musicians a long --
for a long time, there --
there was this ego attachment.
There was one -- I remember David
Sanborn talking to me about it.
It's an ego attachment to
that record label name,
you know, the "I'm on Warner.
I'm" -- Maybe there was something
to that, and I think the idea
of doing these things, you
know, doing the documentation.
But I think more and more
people now are realizing
as everything, you know.
It's like -- Have you ever
watched a spider suck the life
out of an insect in a web?
>> Larry Appelbaum: Not lately.
>> Maria Schneider: Well,
I have when I was a kid.
We used to every once in a while,
we had a window, and there was --
I remember one night, my sister was
watching out the window this spider,
and so my mom got us all there.
And I remember seeing that
spider just suck the life --
And that's what -- That's
the image I always get
of what this is doing to musicians.
It's just sucking the
life out of them.
I mean, the copyright report
from the office of copyrights
that they did, going around,
studying, you know, what --
how the DMCA is affecting people.
And they said 80 percent of the
song writers in national have quit.
So this is like, you know -- this
is just an astounding figure.
So I think as more
and more people start
to realize what they're giving
away, they're going to realize
that self-ownership is really
key and owning ones' own data.
I mean, people are
just really behind.
They're just starting to wake up.
And I've noticed -- I mean Brian
was just way ahead of his time.
That -- I think that's
the main thing.
But I think people are waking up
and I think it is going
to start to happen.
He just started something
called Fan Funded.
It's going to be like
for the masses.
It's kind of like ArtistShare
a little, you know,
but a little easier and not
requiring quite so much --
doesn't give quite the
benefit that I have, but I --
I am hoping that more and more
people are going to do this.
I love the idea about the music
industry basically being the music
industry, you know, being
the people that make it
and owning our own stuff
and taking control again.
It's this, I don't know.
It could really -- There could
be a critical mass change
over that could really
change things for the better
and requiring transparency.
Transparency is so key.
>> Larry Appelbaum: Have you
noticed any movement to address some
of these inequities
in higher education?
For example, musicians
learn their --
They become trained
in how to play music.
They -- Most of them take some
kind of business of music course,
but I wonder as more and
more musicians graduate
from these schools from
conservatories, how aware are they
in some of these issues
and how well do they know
that there's a choice for them?
>> Maria Schneider:
Not aware enough.
I mean that is one of the things
that I brought to the table
with Musicanswers is I said,
"This has to be as much
about the young student musician --
>> Larry Appelbaum: Yeah.
>> Maria Schneider: -- as it
is about the professional,
because they're the ones that really
have been kind of brainwashed,
that this is just really cool to put
up all your favorite music on a --
on a channel and you're somehow --
YouTube channel and you're somehow
helping everybody and yourself.
And they don't realize
that they've been taught
to cannibalize themselves for --
and they're cannibalizing themselves
for somebody else's gain and
they don't even realize it.
And those things are not taught.
They're still teaching.
Some people are.
Some schools are, but mainly,
you know, they're teaching kind
of the old business and a little bit
about the social media
and all that stuff.
And my goal is to wake
everybody up and start --
I've been starting to write to
deans and say, will you send this
to every -- We want every
faculty member and every student
at your school to endorse
this and start watching and --
We're into educating them
about what's really going on,
the things that people do not
know and are not awake to.
So, yeah, that's tops on my -- on
my agenda for what I want to do.
>> Larry Appelbaum: I loved
hearing this image you cite
about the spider sucking the life.
It's not so much the sucking part.
It's that that's an image from
your childhood that has stayed
with you all these years.
And so for people who know
about your music and they listen
to your recordings, but
they may not know that much
about you personally
and your background.
You grew up in Windom, Minnesota?
>> Maria Schneider:
Uh-huh, southwest Minnesota.
>> Larry Appelbaum: And
is that prairie land?
>> Maria Schneider:
It's prairie land.
It's farm land.
There's some native prairie
there left, very little patches,
beautiful wide open
landscape, you know, flat,
far as the eye can see, beautiful.
>> Larry Appelbaum: And does
that impact or in what way does
that impact your aesthetic
or your artistic identity?
>> Maria Schneider: You
know, it's so amazing.
It's like when you --
As you're coming up
and you're doing things you don't
realize what's impacting you,
and then you look back
and you start to see?
And what -- First of all, when I
was a kid, I loved Aaron Copland,
and I think there was --
not the modern Aaron Copland
because I didn't know it.
You know, I knew more
of the Appalachian spring
and the, you know --
>> Larry Appelbaum: Right.
>> Maria Schneider: -- but there was
something about the openness of that
that I related to, the
landscape of things.
And I've always been -- Even
earlier today, I was telling you
about my piano teacher, this
extraordinary teacher, Mrs. Butler,
who had been a stride
pianist in Chicago.
She was married to
one of the pianists
from the Glenn Miller
band, her second husband.
She was also a great
classical pianist,
and she was a great
organist, red hair with a face
like Dizzy Gillespie kind
of, you know, very flamboyant
with rhinestone-studded
glasses, red hair and wore like,
you know, moo-moo's and, you know.
She was just an amazing,
amazing woman.
And my first lesson she taught
me, started teaching me theory.
And she taught me to understand
why the music I played felt the way
it felt.
So the one-four-five
chord would be, here we --
here we go up the hill back again
home, to show the four going up,
the five bringing you
back home is tonic.
She had -- Before that, it was
bright the day with a major triad,
dark the night with a minor triad.
So, I've always equated maybe
the visual to music, and I've --
Much of my music has
been about something.
And I don't set out to
write about something.
It's that I start writing,
and before I know it,
I'm on top of the silo of the
Thompson Farm in Windom, Minnesota,
and I'm seeing those
beans, and I'm like,
Oh my god, that feels like that.
Maybe it's a way to bring back
memory and freeze it into --
into a new form that
I can relive it.
It might be that.
It might be -- Because I
love it like if my band plays
and whatever it was that
was going into that music.
Like I say, the idea -- Usually
when the idea first comes,
it's just a musical idea.
Then it attaches a
lot of times itself
to a memory or an idea or something.
And what I love is in the
end when the band plays that
and I'm standing there conducting
it, and all that imagery is coming
to me, to the point sometimes
where it makes me cry.
You know, I'm like, wow, I am there.
It's just so -- such a powerful
attraction to that moment,
and I don't know why
that's how it clicks
for me in my head but it does.
>> Larry Appelbaum: I assumed that
you would need to have a detachment
in order to pay all attention to
detail and performance, and yet,
I'm hearing that you
get caught up in it.
>> Maria Schneider: Oh yeah.
>> Larry Appelbaum:
Just as [inaudible].
>> Maria Schneider:
Very much, very much.
I mean I am definitely,
you know, detail, you know,
cut of this breath, you know, that's
a little out of tune, you know,
look at somebody here, you know,
want a little more trumpets.
Can you play that a little smoother?
There's always that going on.
But there are moments
that when it's happening,
you're just -- you
just get lost in it.
You just say, oh, you
know, yeah, definitely.
>> Larry Appelbaum: Did
you study conducting
or is this something
that happens naturally?
>> Maria Schneider: I
studied a little bit.
I took some lessons in
Minnesota undergrad,
some classes with the
conducting teacher at Eastman.
He -- The poor man,
Donald Hunsberger.
He was charged with teaching
all the jazz musicians how
to conduct, you know.
>> Larry Appelbaum: Poor man.
>> Maria Schneider: Poor man.
But I -- It was funny,
recently, I had to conduct --
Well a few years back, I had
to conduct the same Paul Chamber
Orchestra, and I called him up.
I said, Don, can I -- You know, it's
years, decades later, Don can I come
up and have a little
conducting lesson?
Can we talk about this piece?
And he was just very sweet about it.
But, you know, conducting my band
is something that just evolved.
And what is, you know, my band's
playing and I would just --
You don't need to conduct
a big band in the --
I mean you need some
of that technique,
because there are always
moments where you need, you know,
the little break, the lift,
the rubato, this and that.
So you need conducting
technique, but it's not the same
as in an orchestra where the
conductor's kind of the --
You've got a rhythm section usually.
There's something keeping time.
For me with -- with my band, it's
more about giving them the picture,
because the trumpets are back there.
They're not really
hearing the reads.
Everybody's kind of separate.
I see myself as a focal
point to keep them focused
on where the music is so they
don't just get in their part,
try and go into auto-play,
because they're not maybe
hearing the pictures so well,
because it's that --
I'm that picture
and I'm letting them know,
is this feeling right?
You know, they can see it in
my body and if something is --
And I kind of look at
them and I go like that,
you know, then they get it.
So for me, it's more about sculpting
this thing so that it is emotional,
that it's not just technically,
yes, I want it technically right,
because that also helps
bring out the emotion.
But bringing out the right
crescendo, flavor, you know,
just the little things that -- that
are going to make me feel like I'm
on that silo as opposed to, you
know, that it's a good piece --
good sounding piece
of music, you know.
>> Larry Appelbaum: There's -- I --
I've no doubt that you've seen it.
In fact, many of the viewers of
this will have seen it, but in 1959,
CBS Broadcast, something
called, The Sound of Miles
or The Sound of Miles Davis.
So it's Miles with his quintet,
and then there's an orchestra led
by Gil Evans, and they did
some of their collaborations.
And I love watching Gil conduct.
It's like a --
>> Maria Schneider:
Yeah, it's kind of
>> Larry Appelbaum: -- big bird.
>> Maria Schneider: Yeah, yeah, the
kind of long hands and the arms --
>> Larry Appelbaum: Yeah.
>> Maria Schneider: -- and it's
-- Yeah, they're something.
It's some about Gil, yeah.
It's just his movement.
>> Larry Appelbaum: We should talk
a little bit about Gil because along
with Bob Brookmeyer, Gil Evans
is the musician, arranger,
composer of who -- who
you're often associated with.
I love the story about how
you first came to meet Gil.
>> Maria Schneider: Yeah.
>> Larry Appelbaum:
Will you tell it?
>> Maria Schneider: Yeah, so I was
a music copyist in New York eight --
>> Larry Appelbaum: By the way, what
does that mean, a music copyist?
>> Maria Schneider:
Okay, so -- so before --
before computers back when we were
young with something called and pad
and ink, and -- Yeah, so this
-- the composer makes the score
and somebody has to make
all those individual parts
for all the players, and that
calligraphy is a real art.
And thank god I had a wonderful
teacher, great composer,
Dominique Argento, back at
the University of Minnesota.
And whenever -- And he
taught me orchestration,
great orchestration
teacher, wow, brilliant.
And all our orchestration exercises,
he made us do in calligraphy pen,
and he said, because that's just
the skill I want you to learn to do.
Well, it was so fantastic because by
the time I left Eastman and I wanted
to move to New York, I had a skill.
And so there's these
music copying offices.
There were.
We looked at one of
the things today.
It was a --
>> Larry Appelbaum: Charlap?
>> Maria Schneider: Yeah, Bill --
not Bill Charlap -- Emile Charlap.
It was a -- it was a -- was
a Brookmeyer score and --
>> Larry Appelbaum: Yeah.
>> Maria Schneider: -- and on the
bottom of the page, I said, oh,
I want to see who copied this,
and it was Emile Charlap.
So his office was right around
the corner, all in mid-town.
In that -- in that office
at one time, you know,
all the arrangers sat
there, the copyists.
It was a music production.
You know, they had somebody,
Ray Charles making a
record or something.
They were sitting there all
writing these arrangements.
>> Larry Appelbaum: Like a
factory or an assembly line.
>> Maria Schneider: Well that
whole area was like that.
The Brill --
>> Larry Appelbaum: Yeah.
>> Maria Schneider: Have you read
that book, The Brill Building --
>> Larry Appelbaum: Yeah.
>> Maria Schneider: --
the book about, yeah,
music in the air or whatever.
It's just -- There was a time there.
Wow. It must have been amazing.
So --
>> Larry Appelbaum: So you came
at the tail-end of that time?
>> Maria Schneider: Well yeah,
I would say a little past the
tail-end, but there were still,
yeah -- 1985, there were
still music copying offices,
and so I got a job in one.
And I also ran these big --
You know, they had these huge
Xerox machines for the big scores.
I miss all that stuff, you know.
And you'd -- The machine, you
could put the parts through,
like if you were doing a long
like three page part, you could --
and the -- You know, then
you'd just have to fold it.
You didn't have to print
all the individual pages.
It was amazing.
So one day this composer,
Tom Pierson came in,
wanted me to print
a score for him --
was kind of a dance classical thing.
And he -- and I got talking
and I was really starved
for conversation about music.
I'd left Eastman, you know.
Every night at dinner, we're
talking and now I live in New York,
and all that community of minds
always churning out over music,
you know, I just wasn't with that.
So, I think he and I got together
for lunch after that I was on my way
out to mail something or -- Anyway,
we got talking, and he asked me
who my favorite writers were,
and I started talking about Gil.
And he just listened.
And then we went to a
Penderecki concert I remember.
But that night, he was
talking about Penderecki.
He didn't even mention
much about Gil.
And then he called me and he
said, I didn't tell you today,
but Gil happens to be
like my closest friend.
And I called him, and
I told him about you,
and he needs somebody
to do some work for him.
And what's crazy about
it is I was so into Gil.
And Gil was the one that
really -- Gil and Brookmeyer --
Well, so many of them made me
want to be a jazz composer,
but it really -- Largely, the reason
Gil and Bob were so powerful for me
that way was that Gil had
-- It's big band music.
It's jazz, you know, but it had
all that transparency, the nuance,
the stuff starting with
the Claude Thornhill.
We looked at the Arab --
>> Larry Appelbaum: Arab --
>> Maria Schneider: -- Dance
score from the Claude Thornhill.
That music, you know, back then,
you know, it's like big bands were
like this thing, and then it's
got this airy sound and mixing it
with classical and I love that.
And then Bob Brookmeyer had
the thing of forms, you know,
forms that you find
in classical music.
So bringing together -- So it wasn't
just this definable jazz thing,
you know.
So I was -- Way back then,
this is before I even went
to Eastman or moved to New York.
One night I was sitting on the couch
and I was listening to Svengali,
and I was looking at the picture
of Gil on the Priestess album.
And I had this whole vision --
like literally, it just kind
of came to me working for Gil.
So when that whole thing happened to
me, I was like, this is just freaky.
It was -- And the first time I saw,
I met him with some
rehearsal studio.
He said, come to the
I'll meet you.
I'll give -- They were rehearsing
and he wanted me to
copy some things.
He came with like a
little sketch this big --
this little King brand music with
the whole score on each line,
you know, all the little notes,
you know that made up the entire,
so I'd have to -- I was like,
wow, okay, this is some kind of --
This is a different kind
of copy job, you know.
But when I first met him,
he came walking towards me.
I was so excited and freaked out
that it's like my whole field
of vision went just
haywire, and he was like,
flying around the room almost.
I had to literally like put
my hand out and shut my eyes
because I couldn't --
I couldn't take it in.
He was almost like a -- like a,
you know, like a shamanistic sort
of experience of, you
know, somebody --
And if ever there was somebody
who was probably a musical
shaman, that would be Gil.
>> Larry Appelbaum: Of his
music, what has the sort
of dearest place in your heart?
>> Maria Schneider: Oh wow.
It's been different, different
pieces -- hard to say.
The Barbara song.
>> Larry Appelbaum:
From the Individualism?
>> Maria Schneider:
The Individualism
of Gil Evans is [makes musical tune]
-- You know that sound of the flute
and -- And the way he -- I couldn't
believe it, it was only years later
that I heard the original
Barbara song
and how fast it moves
and [makes song tune].
>> Larry Appelbaum: Kurt Vile.
>> Maria Schneider: Yeah, Kurt
Vile, you know, it's like --
And the words are something
very strange.
And Gil just recomposed it
into this long, haunting thing.
So, I think that one for me
maybe has the most magic.
But then there's so much stuff.
Oh boy, I don't know.
God, there's so many.
One of the great Gil Evans
arrangement Ryan Truesdell did
on his new album.
It was, "How About You."
Just a -- And that one he
heard about from Brookmeyer.
He knew to look for it and start
digging to find this thing,
because Bob Brookmeyer said
years ago I played a rehearsal
for the Thornhill Band.
Gil came in with this
arrangement of, "How About You,"
and it was just crazy great.
And it was never recorded.
And he ended up digging that out.
That thing is amazing.
Oh my Gosh.
>> Larry Appelbaum: I love
Gil's arrangements for singers.
>> Maria Schneider: Oh yeah.
>> Larry Appelbaum: And I know
you've used Luciana Souza among
others with your orchestra.
How do you feel about
writing for voices?
>> Maria Schneider: I love it.
I love it.
Yeah, if it takes forever.
With Astrud Gilberto, that thing --
that arrangement he
did is so beautiful.
You know, I wrote for Dawn Upshaw.
>> Larry Appelbaum: Oh that's right.
>> Maria Schneider:
See, I wrote for --
Luciana started because I
wanted that human element.
I -- And a piece that was on
Concert in the Garden, The Bulerias
and she -- she sang, she is so
beautiful at making her voice
like an instrument, mixing in --
>> Larry Appelbaum: Yeah.
>> Maria Schneider: -- but then
you've got that human thing.
So I started using that in my music
with Luciana just on recording.
We didn't do it much live because
having a singer with a big band
in that kind of context live
from an engineering
standpoint is just a nightmare.
She doesn't hear herself
enough or, you know,
or if somebody mixes it too loud.
So, it's not something
I do live very much.
But years later, then
Dawn Upshaw comes to me
and wants me to commission her.
And that started from the same Paul
Chamber Orchestra I did I think
called, The Carlos
Drummond de Andrade Stories.
And then she asked for
another one and I did a suite
of nine Ted Kooser songs.
Ted Kooser was just
my favorite poet.
I just love him.
He lives in Lincoln,
Nebraska -- poet laureate --
He was poet laureate and
a Pulitzer Prize winner.
And I did nine of his poems from
his book, Winter Morning Walks,
a hundred postcards to Jim Harrison.
And what I found was so wonderful,
especially in doing
the Kooser stuff,
because that poetry,
I related to so much.
It's very Midwestern.
It's very plain spoken
but profoundly beautiful.
And what I discovered is, you know,
I've been writing instrumental
music for so many years.
And you're pulling every idea,
and if there is that story.
Everything's coming out of you.
Suddenly, when I was
working with this poetry,
the poetry was giving
me the imagery.
The poetry was giving me the rhythm
of the, you know, of the words
and even hinting at where
that melody would want to go.
So, it was almost like somebody
taking my hand and say, okay,
this is the basic outline.
This is the sketch, you know.
It -- I don't know.
It just -- It needed -- I don't
want to say the word is easy,
but it just -- it made it less
effortful, you know, or something.
There was just something
about it that it just came --
It felt like somebody just
giving you a little --
a little boost into
a direction and --
and I love that music and music
is very close to my heart.
One of the pieces I -- when
I was coming here last night,
one of them came up on my
iPOD, and it was, "Spring."
The sky rippled with
geese with this --
but the green comes on slowly tying
to the ticking of down spouts.
The pond still numb from months
of ice reflects just one
enthusiast this morning,
a budding maple whose every twig
is strong with beads of carves
and a cinnabar, bittersweet red."
And I had done that song, and it was
playing and I just thought this time
of year is so perfect for that.
And I was just like, I love that.
And it's easy to love it
because it's not only my music,
it's music I would've never
written if it wasn't for Ted.
>> Larry Appelbaum: Did
you discuss it with Ted?
>> Maria Schneider: I got
permission of course and --
>> Larry Appelbaum: By the
way, how does that work?
Do you have agent who
does it for you?
>> Maria Schneider: No.
>> Larry Appelbaum: Or do you
literally pick up the phone?
>> Maria Schneider: No, I --
I found him through the
internet, and wrote him.
I was just terrified.
You never know what kind of
person, you know -- you know.
>> Larry Appelbaum: Yeah.
>> Maria Schneider:
You know I'm sure.
Artists, writers, whatever,
they can be anything from open
to the prickliest things
on the planet, you know.
It can be everything, right.
>> Larry Appelbaum: But
usually if you're sincere,
they will at least hear you out.
>> Maria Schneider: Yeah.
>> Larry Appelbaum: Yeah.
>> Maria Schneider:
Well, he was very open.
I think he had --
>> Larry Appelbaum: Did
he know who you were?
>> Maria Schneider: No.
And I think he had no real
expectation, you know, of anything.
And then -- and I didn't
-- He doesn't --
he isn't much into traveling.
He does it here and
there but not a lot.
So I invited him to come
to the premier and Ojai,
and he didn't much want to go.
And then I didn't have him here
until I finished the record,
and I sent it to him, and
I was so scared, because --
First of all, these
poems -- this book --
I don't know if you
know about this book,
but he -- he wrote those poems.
He was recovering cancer treatment,
and he couldn't be in the light.
So he started going on
these early morning walks,
and he was very depressed,
and he wasn't writing.
And then one morning,
he went on a walk.
He tells the story at the
beginning of the book.
He came back from a walk and he
wrote down a poem and he put it
on a postcard, and sent it
to Jim Harrison, his friend.
And then the next day, and it kind
of I think probably became
a little bit of his lifeline
and brought him back, you
know, writing these poems.
So one of them, that's my
favorite maybe that I used was,
"Walking by flashlight at six in
the morning, my circle of light
on the gravel swinging side to side.
Coyote, raccoon, field
mouse, sparrow,
each watching from darkness, this
man with the moon on a leash."
So, you know, it's just
such beautiful imagery.
And so, I was so scared for him
to hear the music because I knew
that these poems were so for him.
You know, they had to be so
close to his heart, you know.
I'm sure all of his poetry
is, but I was just terrified.
And I got up one morning
early, you know,
and I glanced at --
Because I just sent it.
I FedEx'ed it to him,
and there was an email
from him, and he just loved it.
It was this long email
and it was just so --
And I remember I was so beautiful.
I mean I was so -- so moved
that he thought it was beautiful
that I started to cry and I --
I went back to bed and
said to Mark, "He likes me.
He likes -- " You know, I was
just -- I'm going to cry now,
because I was so relieved, because
I loved that poetry so much.
So, you know.
It's scary to put somebody's words
to music, and it's a responsibility.
And --
>> Larry Appelbaum: Has
anyone used your music
or repurposed it for something else?
>> Maria Schneider: A few
people have rearranged it
and made it into things.
One of the most beautiful -- You're
not even going to believe this,
because I -- One day my -- the guy
who handles my publishing, you know,
administration, he said there was
a Drummond Bugle Corp that wants
to do a version of Sky Blue.
>> Larry Appelbaum: Oh.
>> Maria Schneider: Sky
Blue is this ballad of mine.
I thought Drummond
Bugle -- I'm going to --
I was like, okay, whatever,
you know.
It was kind of like Ted, you know,
probably the low expectation,
you know.
And they sent me a
video of this thing.
It is one of the most moving,
beautiful arrangements.
It's so beautiful.
It's beyond, and they had videos
of the kids singing all the parts,
you know, in preparation.
They were all singing.
Then they showed them just
standing there and playing.
And then they showed
them on the field
and they all had these spandex light
blue -- You might be able to find --
I don't know if they have a website
where they show that, but t-shirt --
blue spandex shirts with
clouds and -- It was --
it was a group called
the Blue Coats,
and their -- It was beautiful.
And so -- and some people
have made small group versions
of Torben Waldorff,
of Choro Dancado.
I mean my music is so kind of frozen
into a shape that is, you know.
It's not like a tune, you
know, that you easily just kind
of turn into something else.
So when somebody does it,
it's kind of a notable thing,
so it doesn't happen a lot.
>> Larry Appelbaum: Now do
people who may, you know,
let's say an ensemble somewhere
who might want to perform some
of your works, do they
have access to the music?
>> Maria Schneider: Yes.
I sell --
>> Larry Appelbaum:
Through your publishing?
>> Maria Schneider: I --
I self-publish my music
all through Artistshare.
So it's -- so everybody --
And so what we do is, yeah,
people can buy the scores in
parts, and then we include a video
of me talking about
how I conduct it.
I include videos of
guys in my band talking
about how they approach playing the
solos or maybe the comping or it --
depending -- Each one
has different videos.
And we also do a thing
on my last recordings.
Well you know a lot
about engineering,
so everything's recorded
multitrack and with --
The soloists are always in a
soundproof booth or usually.
They have been on my last records.
And so we make a version
with the soloist mixed out.
And then I put with that --
So then I can include that so
that the student solos can
practice along with my band.
So all those kinds of things are.
Yeah, I figured out a
way to share and publish
and do everything I can
through that website.
>> Larry Appelbaum: Can I assume
that when you write, you often write
with specific people in mind --
>> Maria Schneider: Absolutely.
>> Larry Appelbaum:
-- in your orchestra?
>> Maria Schneider: Yeah.
>>>> Larry Appelbaum: Can
you give me an example
of how you might write
for a specific soloist?
>> Maria Schneider: I don't
think I can give you an example
and I'll tell you why.
So people always say
this about Ellington --
>> Larry Appelbaum: Yeah.
>> Maria Schneider: It's
probably the most talked
about aspect of Ellington.
He wrote for his players
and what I --
what I would say about
that is that you --
If you work with people night
after night and year after year,
you can't help but do that.
You have a way of relating
and taking them
in with what you put out.
It's very much like conversation.
You're talking to me one way.
If your mother was sitting here,
you'd talk to her a different way.
If a -- your closest
friend was sitting here,
you'd maybe have a highly
inappropriate conversation
about something, you know.
>> Larry Appelbaum:
We could do that.
>> Maria Schneider: Who
-- who knows what --
>> Larry Appelbaum: Yeah.
>> Maria Schneider:
-- what it would be?
And so it's the same
thing, you know.
It's just your gut
makes you do something.
So, I don't know if I
can put it into words.
And maybe sometimes now though I
think I really write for my soloist
and tuned into what they do, I also
know that sometimes maybe I kind
of typecast them, because I have an
idea in my head about who they are
and sometimes for fun, you know,
we'll be on a tour and I'll switch
around solos to shake things up.
And it's like, okay, let's give this
to this person tonight or whatever.
And an instrument and a person
that I never imagined playing
a certain solo will do it,
and all of a sudden, it
turns it into something
that I just never imagined
that I love.
And so -- so, yeah, to say
an example of how I do it;
well Scott Robinson
-- Let's pick Scott.
Scott can do so many things with
his instrument, and he is somebody
who is coming from a deep respect
of everything very
traditional all the way
to Sun Ra and beyond, you know.
So -- so he's got this wide scope.
So with Scott, you know that you can
do things that don't just require,
you know, fitting in, you know,
really beautiful melodic way
to a harmonic thing, but that
can go kind of creatively beyond
into sort of a sonic spectrum.
I mean there's that, but
then also kind of knowing too
where his heart can go
as a musician too --
what he can get into and
what he might not get into.
So I try to hit that.
For me, the hardest part with all --
with the guys and this stuff is
when we're rehearsing and trying
to describe to them in rehearsal
what I want, so that we can get it
to a certain point so
that then they get it,
and then now they can take
it to their own point.
But that first initial thing of,
no, no, no, can you try it this way?
Can you do that?
You know, it -- it can be very
antithetical to creativity
and you have to just kind of muscle
it into some sort of understanding
and then -- then the thing freeze
up and then they take it some place.
I don't know.
I wasn't expecting.
>> Larry Appelbaum: There
are some very creative people
in your orchestra.
>> Maria Schneider: Oh yeah.
>> Larry Appelbaum:
Because you mentioned Scott.
He not only has this wide palate of
what he's likely to do as a creator,
but he also has all
these instruments --
>> Maria Schneider: Yeah.
>> Larry Appelbaum:
-- they can create on.
>> Maria Schneider: Yes.
>> Larry Appelbaum: And I
wondered if you ever write
for a contrabass saxophone?
>> Maria Schneider: Yes.
>> Larry Appelbaum: You do?
>> Maria Schneider: Yeah, yeah.
Sometimes -- Well, you
know what, if I do that --
Well contrabass clarinet
is in the Bulerias.
I generally don't do
it as a -- as --
I do it as this could possibly
be played on this also,
because getting a contrabass
saxophone on an airplane,
you know -- There are -- there are
practicalities that you have to --
So, we'll experiment
with those things
and contrabass trombone,
George Flynn.
But I love when Scott brings
out these wild instruments,
you know, and plays things.
I just -- I love it and the audience
loves it, and it's just so --
>> Larry Appelbaum: It's
visually interesting also --
>> Maria Schneider: Yeah, yeah.
>> Larry Appelbaum: --
to watch your orchestra.
I suppose I should ask you
about your brush with one
of the most famous,
let's say rock icons,
and that's David Bowie
at the end of his life.
>> Maria Schneider: Yeah.
>> Larry Appelbaum: Why don't
you talk a little bit about what
that experience meant to
you and how it played out?
>> Maria Schneider:
Well, I'll tell you.
The biggest way, it's -- I
mean it's how it's played.
This piece that I wrote
for you, for the Library
of Congress would not
have been written
if it weren't for David Bowie.
>> Larry Appelbaum: Really?
How so?
>> Maria Schneider: There
is no question about that.
Well, so he came to me
about working on this song
that he was -- had started.
He gave -- he came with
a, like a little recording
of something he had put together.
It was the beginnings of
something, but it wasn't developed
into this long thing and --
>> Larry Appelbaum:
And he knew about you
or did you know each other already?
>> Maria Schneider:
No, I'd never met him,
but he had come to hear the band.
>> Larry Appelbaum: Got it.
>> Maria Schneider: And somebody
had once written to me about,
you know, would you sign some CDs?
I want to give them to
David for this birthday.
So I knew David liked my music, that
he came to hear the band one night,
and he was gone before the
-- I had a chance to say, hi.
And then out of the blue, I'd
heard he was looking for --
for me, and he called me about
collaborating on this song together.
And I was very, very nervous
about it, because I just --
It's like David Bowie,
and I just thought,
what if I don't meet his
expectation or you know?
So I kept saying to him, okay, you
just have to promise me if you don't
like it, you can just say so.
That's okay, you know.
I was just constantly doing that.
And then once we were --
decided we were going to go ahead
and I listened to the thing and
he was sitting there, you know,
and I heard it, and I
went over to the piano,
and I started playing around.
And I said, so you
want this to be dark?
Because I said this doesn't
sound super dark to me.
He said, I want it dark.
And so I was playing
around, and I said, okay.
I said, I'll do it.
I said, let's -- I think I hear
-- I said, I don't want to say,
yes unless I feel like I can
really bring something to it.
Of course, who doesn't want
to work with David Bowie?
But I didn't want to work with David
Bowie unless I felt like I was going
to do something he was
going to be happy with.
So -- so then I worked on
some ideas or, you know,
we talked about a little bit.
He left and then he came back.
And then I brought some
ideas to the table.
Then we started working together
on it, and we met a few times,
and we put together
a little session.
But somewhere in there, you
know, I was like, David,
this is going to be
really expensive.
What we're doing is
kind of a crazy thing.
And what if it's not good?
What if you don't like it?
And he said, Maria,
the plane goes down.
He said, everybody walks away.
So -- so --
>> Larry Appelbaum: Yeah.
>> Maria Schneider: You know and
I'm a person who I go in a crisis.
When people call me
to do a commission,
many composers are happy.
I'm like, oh, no, not a commission,
because I know I'm going to --
That means I'm going
to torture myself.
I'm going to have several
months of self-loathing.
>> Larry Appelbaum: Is that true?
Are you really like this?
>> Maria Schneider: Absolutely.
>> Larry Appelbaum: But that doesn't
come from insecurity, does it?
>> Maria Schneider: Of course.
>> Larry Appelbaum: Really?
>> Maria Schneider: Deep-seated --
>> Larry Appelbaum: I would not have
imagined you as an insecure person.
>> Maria Schneider: Are you serious?
Oh, yeah. When it comes to the
writing and everything, oh yeah.
>> Larry Appelbaum:
And it's every time?
>> Maria Schneider: Oh, I have
-- I have -- Every time I hear --
>> Larry Appelbaum: Wow.
>> Maria Schneider: -- new
music, I go in a crisis
and many times have been in tears
at rehearsals including yesterday.
>> Larry Appelbaum:
Who'd of thought?
>> Maria Schneider: Yeah,
it can happen to me.
Yeah, I just get frustrated.
It's hard for me to
figure it all out.
Every time, it is so --
>> Larry Appelbaum: But
Bowie gave you some cues
that said that, yes, she hears it --
>> Maria Schneider: It's okay.
>> Larry Appelbaum: Yeah.
>> Maria Schneider: So when
I was writing this piece,
and David liked my intense stuff.
So he wanted this piece
to be kind of a Sue.
It ended up being called Sue
or In the Season of Crime.
He wanted this drum and bass fast,
kind of drums going under this thing
and this whole thing was just
kind of this intense thing.
And then I created this sort
of rubato stuff over the top.
Well, somehow that whole
concept has just been in my head,
and he liked my intense music.
And as I started working
on this idea,
all of a sudden I just realized this
is a continuation of David -- David.
And David would really
love this piece.
I know he would love this piece.
It might not be quite fully formed.
I may have to do some editing
yet, but I think he would --
he would love what I'm doing.
My assistant Marie, she was at the
rehearsal when I was playing it.
She said, "David would love this."
And I said, "Yeah,
I think he would,"
which makes me happy, you know.
And I -- So these gestures
that I do in the ensemble
where the band just
goes -- the band --
the rhythm section's
cooking along and there's --
the soloist is going or whatever
and the band just starts
going [makes musical noise].
That's the kind of thing.
I would've just -- I don't know if
I would've ever risked doing it.
And I -- When I threw it in front
of my band, it was just like,
I'm just going to do this.
The plane goes down, whatever.
We do all walk away.
You know, that's art.
We take the risk and we try
it and we see what happens.
And so, I did this piece with --
Even though I will tell you, yes,
it's been stressful, I did it
with more joy and more like,
throw it to the wind,
see what happens,
than I would've because of him.
And I kept having his face in my
head of him just smiling and that --
I still remember him looking, you
know, just smiling and just --
And at the -- and when we were
recording, seeing his face
through the glass and just smiling,
just enjoying doing this
thing with the band.
You just -- You know, he
loved Kenton, loved Kenton.
>> Larry Appelbaum:
Oh, I didn't know.
>> Maria Schneider: Yeah.
And he loved jazz and
he loved big band music,
and then his last album
ended up being with Donny.
So --
>> Larry Appelbaum: Donny McCaslin.
>> Maria Schneider: Yeah.
He had wanted to do one
more piece with me --
>> Larry Appelbaum: Yeah.
>> Maria Schneider: -- and we talked
even about doing much more, but --
and I think we would've
done much more.
>> Larry Appelbaum: Did you know
at the time that he was dying?
>> Maria Schneider: No, no.
But -- but I didn't have
time to do another piece,
because I was doing the Thompson
Fields, my newest record, so --
And I -- and I didn't even have time
for Sue, but I did it, you know,
but that summer was just so
cramped and busy and stressful.
And so I just said I just
only have the time for one,
but the other piece ended
up becoming Lazarus.
And I'm so glad that they did it.
And I had said to him.
I -- When he was describing to me
the whole drum and bass and the jazz
and everything, I said, you have
to listen to Donny McCaslin.
I -- So I said, let me get --
I pulled out, you know,
the recordings I have.
I said, listen to this.
And he just loved it.
I said, you should
work with these guys.
This would be amazing.
This would be an unbelievable
combination.
And we went to hear Donny and Tony
Visconte was there, his producer,
and they ended up with Donny's group
doing that last album which for me,
is one of the greatest
albums David made.
It's so beautiful.
It is so evocative.
I love it so much, but then I'm
just wrecked after I listen to it.
So I -- Then I can't listen to it
that last -- the last song on that.
Oh my god.
It's so beautiful.
So I love what David and
I created together on Sue.
I love it.
I love the way he sings on it.
I'm so happy with it.
But even if all that had been was
just to get him connected to Donny
to make that last record,
I would've been like, wow,
that might be musically one
of the greatest things I ever
did is just being that, you know,
little arrow point for him, so.
>> Larry Appelbaum: I'm
glad you both did it.
>> Maria Schneider: Yeah, it's --
Who would think that you'd
affect David Bowie's musical --
last musical project?
Do you know I would've -- I would've
thought I'd be the last person
on earth that would that, you know.
But it just goes to show
you how open musicians are,
how open we are amongst
ourselves and what a world --
a beautiful world of collaboration.
I mean it's -- It is the greatest
world to be a part of and it's
such a privilege, and
there's so much talent.
And there's so much hard
work and creativity.
And I think it's -- Going
back to that other subject,
the nasty subject before,
I think that's why I make this whole
advocacy thing such a huge part
of my life, because it burns my butt
when people not only take advantage
of the financial aspects of,
you know, of people's lives --
It's basically like reaching into
somebody's 401K and saying, hey,
I'm going to give out, you know,
number -- little 15 dollar --
You know, here, everybody,
take a little, you know
and just pick away at it.
It's not just that.
It's eroding the whole
culture of it.
And it's going to affect
the quality of the music,
because if the music can
only then be made just
by these massive record companies
that are pushing these, you know,
teen wonders or whatever
it is just to make money
and get billion streams or whatever,
and so many other musicians are just
like I can't swim amidst
this, you know.
How can I have a family if I
get a check for three cents
or 30 dollars even in this day?
You know I have millions of streams
and got, you know, 17 dollars.
I mean it's like come one.
This isn't -- this is -- this
is going to destroy things,
and it makes me angry
because it's an ecosystem.
It's an amazing ecosystem,
the music industry.
>> Larry Appelbaum: It's fascinating
to hear you talk about it
because within you, there's a
kind of balance between the things
that might arouse your
passion and the things --
the gifts that you've
been given in life.
And the greatest thing
is to find that balance.
>> Maria Schneider: Yeah.
>> Larry Appelbaum: Yeah.
>> Maria Schneider: Not easy.
>> Larry Appelbaum: As a --
I think we have time maybe
for one last question.
>> Maria Schneider: Okay.
>> Larry Appelbaum: As a composer,
as an arranger, band leader,
all the other hyphens, all
the other hats you wear,
how do you measure success?
>> Maria Schneider: How
do I measure success?
I don't know.
Success to me, enjoying
loving what you do and feeling
like it's growing and it's moving.
Because success kind
of implies arrival.
And artists, I think you never
feel like you arrive, you know.
Somebody said to me, what --
Well does it feel good to
get like where you are?
And I said, No, actually not,
because it's an infinite ways to go
and you're always a
beginner on the next.
You know, there's always the
next wrung on the ladder.
And maybe you get to a certain
point of confidence and, you know,
not proving yourself
that makes some plateaus,
but then there's always
that next challenge.
So, success, you know, I think
if you ever even have the feeling
of success, you sort
of are done, you know.
So, maybe success is never
actually feeling success.
I don't know -- I don't know.
>> Larry Appelbaum: A
snake eating its tail --
>> Maria Schneider: Yeah.
>> Larry Appelbaum:
-- Maria Schneider.
>> Maria Schneider: Thank you.
>> Larry Appelbaum:
Thank you very much.
>> Maria Schneider: Thank you.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.